a spectre is haunting online FPS games
it's called Zim in fact it's so popular
that people use the name of this device
like a verb now that guy's ziming you
get it oh Caleb on Zim Caleb on
Zim no no no no no no no that doesn't
mean he's Zim hold up he might just be
running a fast sense these small devices
have caused big problems for the
competitive communities in many console
FPS games every single match was like oh
like this next one I'm probably going to
face a mouse and keyboard user and then
you see them flicking around you're like
oh of course it's it's a mouse and
keyboard user but is this cheating or is
it really case of adapt or adapter well
everybody else does it so why would I
not do it now like when people say it to
me like for like the reasoning on why
they use Zim I'm like like no that that
doesn't make any sense like just get
better on a controller like you're just
adding on to the problem and with so
many of them already out there do
console developers even have a fighting
chance against these
things
[Applause]
before we get into today's topic be sure
to like the video sub to the channel
ring that notification Bell also be sure
to check out our new merch drop over at
shop. thescore.com all right so a little
something called Zim and devices similar
to it has surged in popularity over the
past year or so stirring up some
controversy along the way if this is the
first time you've heard about this let
me explain physically these are
converters or adapters that offer
various functional ities and if you've
ever owned a fight stick or other
specialized peripherals you're familiar
with the basic idea this can be an
external dongle thing or an internal
switch or even a custom PCB that has all
the connections you need to connect to
different systems now Zim and devices
like it are essentially bigger versions
of these dongles but what kind of
functionality are people trying to get
with these things like Zim well we don't
have manufacturer data and even if we
did I wouldn't trust it you could do a
lot of things with a zim but the most
most common use is plugging in your
mouse and keyboard into console games
where that isn't explicitly allowed now
why are people doing things like this in
the first place well it's so they can
get better results in games like Rainbow
Six Siege or OverWatch the main reason
why people use mouse and keyboard on
console is because there's no aim assist
in Siege so aiming with a controller is
very hard if you have mouse and keyboard
it's just going to be easier it's just a
fact of life you have to play
differently cuz like they're just going
to have so much better aim than you like
you're going to verse people who like
you can easily compete compete with the
zims 100% cuz most of them who use them
are not smart by any means so if you
have like a brain to positioning and
game sense you'll win 100% like it's not
like it's stopping you from you know at
all ranking up so sure aiming with the
mouse is going to be better but in some
games you also get aim assist and that's
where this gets really out of hand with
that said let's throw it over to Colton
to talk about how these things work and
what companies are doing about it and
now the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about thanks Seb I uh sorry I'm
a little out of sorts normally I'd have
a quip for Dimitri here but I can't do
that to Seb he's a nice guy uh well many
developers hadn't figured out what to do
about Zim and hadn't even acknowledged
it as a problem until this year in March
2023 Ubisoft announced mouse trap a
program they developed to help identify
Zim users and then lightly troll them
not ban them Activision announced in
April that Ricochet antiche would Target
Z like devices and blizzard hinted at
some vague changes to OverWatch 2 that
were still pending as of September but
these pesky adapters have a far longer
history than these measures would have
you believe their big moment actually
happened around the time Dr Lup let the
world know exactly what a zim meant for
Destiny 2 on PC but how did we get here
first I think it's important to note
that the reason Zim is so popular is
that well mouse and keyboard is the
absolute king of inputs for FPS there
are are some games like Apex Legends
where aim assist for controller players
gives them a fighting chance against
mouse and keyboard purists and if anyone
was doubting the strength of what the
community has dubbed roller Apex Esports
Superstar Imperial Hal already showed us
what it was capable of he switched from
mouse and keyboard to controller and he
won a championship so I decided to
switch a controller and as the first
land I played on controller and I got
MVP won the land so I I feel I feel like
I worked I I took a big risk playing
controller and swapping to something
that I haven't played in for a while and
all paid off there are even sickos out
there like Royal penguin who you saw
earlier in this video who play
controller on PC of their own free will
so for me it's very different so like I
I started off on console and then I went
to PC I do controller PC so I hit
controller PC Champion I'm voluntarily
versing Mouse and keyboards for us mere
mortals though without aggressive assist
it starts to look pretty Grim for thumb
sticks when you pit them against a mouse
and there's pretty good reason for that
a long time ago psychologists were
laying the groundwork for deciding how
humans particularly lay people could
best interact with computers the most
common strategy that emerged is
something generally called the pointing
device and its most common form on the
PC Today is you guessed it a mouse we
take mice for granted now but there are
still other options ultimately a
proposed model for computer human action
called fits law seem to best Express the
problem and basically what it says is
the difficult difficulty of a movement
is related to the size of the target you
want to hit as well as the distance you
have to travel to hit it um so therefore
performance in this sense is related to
how fast you can perform that movement
the mouse has many other advantages as
well like the fact that it just holds
itself up and easily stays stationary
But ultimately it's precise works well
in tandem with the multitude of human
joints and doesn't obstruct the screen
so it's no wonder that people would want
access to mouse and keyboard in a world
where everyone else is flicking sticks
in gunfights one-on-one gunfights like
you have to have better positioning than
them cuz they're just going to have
better aim than you like you're using
two analog sticks and they're using
their entire arm now in nearly every
case Zim and other adapters aren't
supported by the companies that develop
these games but they're still everywhere
this has given rise to what is
essentially a new front in the waron
cheating and one where not every
developer seems eager to fight oh and by
the way some of these adapters control
your recoil for you which is surely
considered cheating even without a mouse
right um I think on Zim so here here's
the biggest thing with Zim right so this
the Zim Matrix came out so basically
what that is is a zim but it also is a
cronis which the cronis is a no recoil
mod so people do it's built in so they
have a mouse and keyboard and they have
a cronis mod Allin one so these things
are out there they are almost
overwhelmingly used to give people
access to a mouse when they shouldn't
have it and as developers have started
to prove you can absolutely detect them
whether it's possible for those devs to
actually start doing anything about it
well I'll hand it back to Seb for that
and that was the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about so without the
accuracy of mouse and keyboard Gamepad
tracking understandably needs and gets a
bit of help from the game and it seems
like there are a lot of people happy
with the amount that's there since M the
keyword has a larger amount of things
that they can do it means that
controller is a worse input and a assist
should be left alone so when it comes to
these adapters the main question right
now is whether or not these things are
really cheating for the communities
around these games and in many cases the
developers the answer is pretty clearly
yes it almost feels like a slap in the
face for creators in the community when
they're's like we do so much to try to
build this up and they just they don't
care to protect 75% of the community
from Che
now whatever excuses zimmers might have
it's clear that using a mouse is an
advantage since a lot of these devices
have built in Recoil compensation too
it's even harder to defend if it's doing
something automatically so you don't
have to that's an easy thumbs down but
the people who Market these devices do
have a few arguments in their defense
firstly they claim that these devices
don't break Xbox or Playstation to which
might technically be correct but
according to the developers of the
titles played on those system systems
that's not necessarily the case for the
games themselves then there's the
general sales pitch letting players
Excel with the input devices that suit
them best which is an admirable
sentiment Ubisoft notably committed to
working with players with disability
requirements by asking them to contact
the devs Via QR code if banned but
clearly any competitive environment
needs limits of some kind I can't just
bring my giant spinbot head loocking ey
win button to a tournament just because
it suits me me best in situations where
the game isn't on PC and the developer
expressly allowed it like Destiny in Dr
lup's case there's really not much to
say it's allowed but that excuse is less
and less relevant in new games Call of
Duty on PS5 now supports mousing
keyboard natively without a zim and
without the aim assist fortnite does too
another argument you see in defensive
Zim sometimes is that using it is like
using a flight stick or driving wheel
it's helping you enjoy the game the way
it's meant to be played but the way a
game is meant to be played in the sense
of what is permitted is again up to the
developer but on Rainbow Six Siege I
don't want to allow you to use it you
know what I mean it's like it's their
game like it's brain dead but even as
more people understand what zims are
capable of they won't actually get you
banned unlike more conventional cheating
methods I think that they should have
just straight off the backone with a ban
I know that that would suck to lose a
big portion of your player base but that
would bring back more people who would
be like oh I stopped playing Siege
because mouse and keyboard was going
crazy I never wanted to play against
that in fact a Siege content creator
that recently received an in-game charm
a prestigious award has received
gameplay penalties from the mouse trap
system on stream between that and the
kid gloves in terms of punishment what
sort of message is being sent here even
if Ubisoft calls it cheating it's like
okay so we're going to give a charm to
somebody who's on a mouse and keyboard
and it's not like it's like oh he's on
mouse and keyboard like they're just
saying that the guy has literally
been caught like it there's a clip of
him getting mous trapped we can
obviously debate on how much
responsibility these devs have but
there's no question that these devices
are having a real impact on their scenes
they also have to realize that if you
were to ban zims so many people would
come back because there are so many
people that are uninterested in playing
the game because of all the zims
especially the Casual scene Zim and
other adapters are so common now they're
reshaping a lot of games I mentioned
that people say ziming but it's more
than just language hand cams are
increasingly common in console
tournaments because these devices are so
easy to get but in a lot of communities
this battle is really just beginning so
then I just report it to the Ubisoft
devs and I just say hey these are like
five to six different methods that are
being used right now um and then I tell
them the method and they they try and
Patch it like that that's the goal at
least and hey maybe one day Ubisoft or
another developer will come in and say
hey stop using this or face actual bands
but honestly we're not counting on it I
think if it does happen it won't be for
a while because in their eyes they're
seeing success with mous trap right and
realistically speaking there is some
success with mous trap so in their eyes
they're like okay well we've put all
this time into mous tra until that day
comes though we had to let the guys give
their parting words to any zimmers who
made it to the end it's not fair just
use a
controller no one's impressed if they
were on a controller they would not even
be in the same lobby as me nor all the
other controller Champions cuz I'm not
the best in the world but I'm at the top
and it's like if they were to use a
controller they would not be in my
lobbies as well as I would also say to
them to just go to
PC thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and Tik Tok